guys I can't concentrate
the birds randos in the neighborhood k1
I'ma be sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
it's a beautiful day outside the birds
are singing and the sun is shining so
obviously it's a great time for a
barbecue and I partnered up with my
friends at flat out flat bread sponsored
this video and collaborated with me to
bring you three takes on everyone's
favorite food pizza now I could eat
pizza Eddy day anyway but when it's so
nice outside I'm busting out the grill
for every single meal and pizza is no
exception
so the key to making your pizza a little
bit later is to go with a thin crust
choose really flavorful cheeses and load
up on the lean protein and healthy bed
so it is beautiful outside I definitely
don't want to be indoors all day making
pizza dough from scratch so I love using
flat out artisans in pizza crusts
honestly these things are amazing too
got 120 calories each 5 grams of protein
2 grams of fiber so they have amazing
space for loading up on those healthy
pizza flavor so let's make pizza ok guys
so the first thing I want to do is
preheat our grill to about medium heat
and I'm just going to get my flat out
out of the bag and I give one a little
spritz with some olive oil in an oil
atomizer that way you get a nice even
coat all the way on top
[Music]
okay so then we're just going to lay
these guys down flat onto the heat for
just about two minutes that's all it
takes
oh yeah those are beauties now we're not
going to grill them on both sides quite
yet because we're going to put all the
goodness on top and put a back on the
grill so that it'll get toasty on both
sides so you don't worry all right
now we decorate first my barbecue
chicken pizza with pineapple and red
onions I throw down a little barbecue
sauce on the bottom on my toasted flat
out and top that with some leftover
chicken some pineapple red onion pickled
jalapenos and some aged cheddar all
right so we're going to pop this back
onto the barbecue and just let it go for
a few minutes until the cheese generally
starts to melt and the bottom gets nice
and crispy next up my pear walnut and
blue cheese pizza I start by smearing a
little ricotta cheese onto the bottom on
my flat out pizza crust and I top it off
with a sliced pear and some blue cheese
call this back onto the grill close the
lid and let the cheese gently melt for
about three to four minutes until the
crust gets nice and crispy on the bottom
finish it off with some time who crushed
toasted walnuts and a drizzle of sweet
honey and bring this baby to mama
finally my corn cilantro pesto pizza
with tomatoes and avocado so first I'm
going to grill a piece of corn on the
cob right onto the grill to get some
nice char marks before removing the
kernels then I'm going to make a pesto
by pairing together some cilantro some
feta almonds garlic and olive oil I'm
going to add the pesto to the base for
our pizza then top it off with some
tomatoes corn feta and return it to the
grill for about three minutes
[Music]
garnished it off with some sliced
avocado and fresh cilantro and we are
ready for a pizza party
[Music]
hey so follow hmm well guys there you
have it free awesome thin crust willable
pieces that are perfect for an alfresco
pizza party if you loved this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below some of your favorite
pizza combinations subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on a
beauticians bond